as an example of a reversible reaction
let's look at the hypothetical reaction
where diatomic gas x2 turns into its
individual atoms
x and it would turn into two of them so
x2 goes to 2x
the forward reaction is x2 turning into
2x and the reverse reaction is 2x
combining to form x2 and let's say the
x2
is a is a reddish brown gas if we assume
that both the forward and the reverse
reactions are elementary reactions
we can actually write the rate law from
the balanced equation
so for the forward reaction let's go
ahead and write the rate of the forward
reaction is equal to the rate constant
for the forward reaction which we will
symbolize as
k with the subscript f times the
concentration of
if we're going in the forward direction
the reactance would be
x2 so times the concentration of
x2 and since we have a coefficient of 1
in front of x2 for this elementary
reaction this would be raised
to the first power next we can write the
rate law for
the reverse reaction so the rate of the
reverse reaction is equal to the rate
constant and we'll put in a subscript
r here so that's the rate constant for
the reverse reaction
and in the reverse reaction 2x
combines to form x2 so this would be
times the concentration of
x and since we have a 2 as our
coefficient
we need to raise the concentration of x
to the second power
next let's look at these particulate
diagrams and think about what happens
for the forward reaction so we start at
time is equal to zero and we start with
only
x two so here are five particles of x
two
if we wait ten seconds now we've gone
from five particles of x two to only
three particles of x x2
so overall two of those particles of x2
have turned
into x and so there are four particles
of
x in this second particulate diagram we
wait another 10 seconds for a total of
time is equal to 20 seconds
and we've gone from three particles of
x2 to only
two particles of x2 and
we've increased in the particles of x so
now we're up to
six particles of x so the concentration
of x2 has
decreased we went from five particles of
x2
to three particles of x2 to only two
particles of x2 and if we look at the
rate law
for the forward reaction the rate of the
forward reaction
is proportional to the concentration of
x2
so if the concentration of x2 decreases
the rate of the forward reaction also
decreases
we can see the same concept if we look
at a graph of rate
versus time so if we look at this line
right here
we're starting at a certain rate for the
forward reaction
and as the concentration of x2 decreases
we can see the rate of the reaction
decrease
so the rate of the reaction stops
decreasing when we get to time is equal
to
20 seconds next let's think about the
rate of the reverse reaction
well when time is equal to zero the rate
of the reverse reaction is zero and
that's because when we start out we have
only
x two we don't have any x present so the
reverse reaction doesn't happen
but as soon as some of that x2 turns
into x it's possible for the reverse
reaction to happen
and as we increase in the amount of x
and we look at our rate law here for the
reverse reaction
as we increase in the concentration of x
the rate of the reverse reaction should
increase
as well and so that's why we see that's
why we see the rate of the reverse
reaction
increase as time increases
so as the forward reaction is happening
the reverse reaction
is also occurring at the same time
however we don't really see that when we
look at our particular diagram
in our particular diagrams we see a net
conversion of x2 into 2x for example
looking from the first particular
diagram to the second
we see that two particles of x2 have
turned into
four particles of x and going from the
second diagram to the third diagram
we see that another particle of x2 has
turned into 2x
and therefore we have six particles of x
at time is equal to 20 seconds so since
we see a net conversion of reactants to
products in our particular diagram
the rate of the forward reaction must be
greater than the rate of the reverse
reaction
and we can see that so before time is
equal to
20 seconds here if we look at our rates
let's just pick
for example times equal to 10 seconds
for the
forward reaction there's a higher rate
than
for the reverse reaction
so at times equal to 20 seconds the rate
of the
forward reaction becomes equal to the
rate
of the reverse reaction so here's the
line on
our graph where the rates become equal
and also notice the rates become
constant at this point and when the rate
of the forward reaction is equal to the
rate
of the reverse reaction the reaction has
reached equilibrium
so to the right of the dotted line the
reaction is at
equilibrium and to the left of the
dotted line
the reaction is not at equilibrium
and since the rate of the forward
reaction is equal to the rate of the
reverse reaction at
equilibrium x2 is turning into 2x at the
same rate that 2x is turning back into
x2 therefore the concentrations of x2
and x at equilibrium remain constant and
we can see that
when we look at the particulate diagrams
for time is equal to 20 seconds and time
is equal to 30 seconds
so both of these particular diagrams
have two
x two particles and six
x particles let's look at a summary of
what the rates of the forward and
reverse reaction mean
in terms of reactants and products if
the rate of the
forward reaction is greater than the
rate of the reverse reaction
that means there's a net conversion of
reactants to products
so therefore over time the amount of
reactants would decrease
and the amount of products would
increase
eventually the rate of the forward
reaction becomes equal to
the rate of the reverse reaction and
that means the reaction is at
equilibrium and there's no net change in
the amounts
of reactants or products so reactants
are turning into products at the same
rate that products are turning back into
reactants
and then finally if the rate of the
reverse reaction is greater than the
rate of the forward reaction
there's a net conversion of products to
reactants so
products are turning into reactants
faster than reactants are turning into
products
in the example that we looked at the
rate of the forward reaction was greater
than the rate of the reverse reaction
and eventually the rates became equal
and the reaction reached equilibrium
if we had looked at an example of this
this third case here where the rate of
the reverse reaction is greater than the
rate of the
forward reaction eventually the two
rates would become
equal and this reaction would reach
equilibrium two